um so because i have a few extra minutes
i like throwing a curve ball or two at
the beginning um and this is not
hard-hitting i promise um top instead of
potatoes
was all right right
very close it was very close
um but the other question was going to
be um if someone has actually never seen
anything that either of you have done
what's the first thing you want them
watching and why
oh oh oh
um
daredevil because i see all the
figurines you have in the back
um
probably uh gravity for me
but the behind the scenes of gravity
but not the movie
yeah not the movie just the behind the
scenes yeah
the whole the whole movie first and then
the behind the scenes
uh sandra i read that you are a big true
crime tv show junkie and i'm and i'm
just curious if someone has really not
gotten into the genre what's like the
one or two that they really need to see
uh what the one that
is i can't yeah i've watched rerun after
re-running you can correct me the
staircase the sir the writer whose wife
died at the base of the stairs
he was a famous writer what was it
called can anyone see anyone else
staircase um might have been called
staircase
fascinating
wealthy white people famous writer
the wife dies at the base of the stairs
somehow the owl theory comes into it
that an owl attacked like it is so
fascinating
and i i i
every time i watch it i see and hear
something else so that one is just the
one that i can't let go rob you need to
watch it
i i'm trying to stay out of the jail
system so i leave that stuff alone i
think he's out of jail
so you can watch this one
okay
jumping into why i get to talk to you um
for each of you what was it actually
about this story these characters that
said i really want to make this
for me
i i can't stress enough man i know
sandra laughs every time i say this but
i was really impressed when i got a
script and it showed a white woman doing
20 years in prison
for whatever the case because we rarely
if at all other than orange is the new
black right but if at all get to see a
true human
story of a white woman doing 20 years in
jail and then when i researched it i saw
that from 2000 to 2019
uh
the state and federal prison
uh population from white women has
increased by 41
and i was like wow that's that's
interesting we never had these kind of
conversations so you know i took that on
as like you know being a part of a film
that could start a healthy dialogue in a
way that we could see what is going on
with our prison
uh
industrial complex system and then also
touch on how
just
uh the biggest flaw to justice is being
poor or having like no resources you
know and and and i felt that this story
where we start with a woman whose family
house is being threatened to take being
taken away from her was something that
we all could could identify with and
resonate with and and i just love being
a part of uh films that that challenge
our ideas of who we are as a society and
and have us come together and start a
healthy dialogue so that was one of my
main attractions all of that
you know all of that lumped into one
steve
how do you follow that
you know the pain of my existence i
follow rob morgan and i'm just silenced
i have nothing
i mean it's everything that rob said and
and you know we want you to judge in
this film we want you to judge heavily
use your
life experience in your eyes in
your journey in life to judge what we're
presenting to you and then as soon as
you think you've got a handle on it we
want you to see the other side
there's always two sides um and being
born into poverty not having resources
makes you unseen to so many why is that
and
80 percent of our our beautiful human
family
is born into poverty and babies are born
into poverty and they are not seen how
do you grow up soft and hopeful
how do you do it
one of the i love talking to actors
about the way they get ready for
performances for for their roles um for
both of you if you have like a really
tough scene on a monday say it's really
dramatic really emotional you know it's
going to take a lot out of you can you
sort of take me through your process
before that monday what exactly are you
doing is it a week out that you're like
starting to stress or like how how do
each of you like to get ready for
something like that
um that's a great question it is a great
question
rob i mean we can't negate our personal
lives too steve you know we still got
stuff we got to do for ourselves at the
same time
prepare for the roads you know i'm
pretty sure we all have our different
approaches but
myself
if that's why the first thing i asked
for is uh the the schedule so i could
see what i'm working on what days coming
up what scenes at least the idea because
sometimes the schedule changes but i try
to see what i'm doing before
and then mentally
while i'm doing everything else in my
everyday life that i have to still
maintain
i'm preparing at the same time and
probably
including parts of my everyday life into
my preparation so that when i show up on
set i can just be that locked in and in
tune
so i bring everything i'm doing really
like the day before all my stuff you
know me you know the letdown i have in
my personal life the how i had in my
personal life you know the confusion i
have in my personal life i can't just
drop all that just because i have an
emotional scene the the day coming up
you know i still have to live that and
bring that to set too
you know with the voice of the character
in mind the truth of the character and
mother
again
recall that
um
yeah it it's it's mine has evolved over
time i think knowing the schedule and
knowing the daunting
fish-eye lens of the date of that scene
is something that used to haunt me so
much um
because you're afraid of failure you're
afraid of not hitting the moment you're
afraid of
letting a team and a crew down who know
we know we have four hours to shoot this
scene and if you don't get it in those
four hours you failed in my
mind but once i had kids i realized
guess what the minute i'm home
i'm theirs so where do i carve out my
time in dark cars with my iphone being
my flashlight is where i learn the lines
after they're asleep right next to me on
the bed is when i have those moments um
i take
who i am to them and who they are to me
into the ruth journey because i i you
know i ask myself all the time what
would i have done and i probably would
have done the same thing
i would have done the same thing
um
because i know how society will be to
them
very different to a mother with white
children
so i take all of that very heavily to
work but then you have to let it go the
minute you're opposite brilliant actors
because your job now is you've done your
homework know your lines let it go and
listen because often what's in your head
and you're playing out this is how i'm
gonna play the scene and this is where
i'm gonna break and guess what
you have no idea what rob morgan's gonna
throw at you to stop you in your tracks
and make you listen you have no idea
what viola davis or vincent or or john
bernthal are gonna throw at you to make
you listen
and your scene takes a complete left
turn that you've been planning for four
months
so i've learned and i think with the
blessing of my babies is that sometimes
you just gotta prepare and let it go
because
someone better is going to come in and
tell you you thought you were going this
way we're going to go take a left
you know and your director comes in and
gives you a note that completely blows
your mind and you haven't seen
um so i've learned to listen just come
prepared
um utilize a dark car in my iphone
flashlight
but still
make time for as rob said home
you got him time for home
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the movie i
really enjoy both of your work thank you
for giving me your time thank you so
much